hey guys donald rumsfeld died
on behalf of the family of the former
u.s defense secretary donald rumsfeld
says that the former secretary of
defense
has passed ironically he was buried with
the two trillion dollars that were lost
right before china
solid gold casket baby away
at the age of 88 in a statement released
by his family 88
[ __ ] based
[ __ ] bass bro i grew 14 year olds he
was 88
boom damn guys represent the connections
man apparently that in part reads it is
with deep sadness that we share the news
of the passing of donald rumsfeld
an american statesman and devoted
husband father
grandfather and great-grandfather and
mastermind behind 911 come on
yeah come on great grandfather and show
some respect
yeah i know i mean really yeah family
in his beloved also it says not a lizard
person just make sure everybody knows
that he's very clear about not being a
lizard person taos
new mexico of course the former
secretary of defense a controversial
figure
and here is a look back at his life by
my colleague peter alexander
i will remember you
immediately show footage of a lizard oh
jesus
it's just a komodo dragon in his glasses
prowling with the [ __ ] twin towers
just crumbling behind it
his entire family lives under a heat
lamp
they're like polly why'd you edit that
in come on that really was like an
all-time greatest moment for opium
anthony
and for louis ck and just for [ __ ]
radio history
that was one of the greatest interviews
ever it was him being asked repeatedly
if he was a lizard
oh i thought you meant with the twin
towers falling i was about to say yeah
i can agree with that we have that clip
i gotta find that clip right
if we had a producer we could probably
get frozen should be doing this smurfs
yeah
yeah be doing the like work babe i don't
want you you know
you know pulling something before the
gym okay look i don't ask
i don't ask asian people to do anything
i'm not willing to do myself
why why they do everything better than
us
everybody lizards except who
i mean literally there's people that
think they're lizards from outer space
yeah that's true who eat human flesh i
don't know if anybody's ever asked you
directly sir but are you
are you a lizard i don't think are you
actually can you just please
give that a straight answer are you a
lizard person louie's a little
left leaning no i'm not i'm not let him
answer are you a lizard here's the short
answer
i'm in new york city i walked down
and then all he had to say was no but he
kept not answering the question
the short answer would be no
not the beginning of your day oh [ __ ]
people walk up shake hands stop me they
want an autograph
i want to get a photograph
[Laughter]
by the way this is a former secretary of
state secretary of defense
a man who worked for four presidents and
and this
is what made that show brilliant
sometimes was having a guy like that on
and completely ruining the moment oh god
that's so amazing
as secretary of defense last night at
dinner and joyce and i were sitting
there in the little italian restaurant
and and a man came up to buy my dinner
he might be
and and it turns out i paid for my
dinner the next thing i know
the waiter comes back and said the man
insisted to pay for your dinner
and here's your cancelled receipt from
me oh wow see there's plenty of people
there
you didn't answer the question
oh [ __ ] but wait a second i just asked
if you were a lizard dude
are you not taking that he's not going
to dignify an answer to
are you a lizard louis why not because
he's
not a lizard what is his story about
getting somebody paid for your dinner
have
i would pay for lizards i think i
understood
i'll post the link if people want to
watch the rest of it it's it's really
good the whole thing's on youtube but
the highlight of that clip is
after doing it several times and anthony
going you know you're disrespecting this
guy he's an american
institution blah blah blah and louis was
like look man
i am not uh i he's like i am in no way
discrediting this man or am i trying to
downplay the fact that he is an american
hero
i just want to know if he's a lizard
from some subterranean oh it was amazing
dude that was one of the greatest
moments in radio i remember hearing that
and just going
this can't be real donald rumsfeld
launched america's wars in iraq and
afghanistan
thank you for your contribution to
society again
we agree thank you for your service
they're saying it like it's great
like donald rumsfeld launched two
different
thank you i mean what do you say to that
they're like what do you want from me
you could have bought halliburton stock
like anybody else
not as early as he did not true
a mission it seems he prepared for his
entire hey look at young rumsey there
huh
life a fierce competitor in wrestling at
princeton a navy pilot
and instructor rumsfeld plunged into
politics
in 1962 and he was quoted as saying i
cannot wait to bomb all those weddings
dude the 60s gave birth to like
a whole new era of evil
that's when all these skull and bone
[ __ ] came out of the woodwork
and just took a country over i thought i
told you to shave those sideburns
rumsfeld
elected to congress four times from
illinois
donald rumsfeld rumsfeld was recruited
by the nixon white house
oh god we're just off to an amazing
everything about this
everything's on the level so far nixon
the reason that we owe china 30 trillion
dollars yeah perfect
so far so good guys allegedly
because you wanted to take a fun trip
and shake hands with chinese people
what you got she earned the reputation
as an ambitious and skillful political
infighter
even president richard nixon called him
ruthless
he later became president ford's chief
of staff and in 1970 now also worked out
really great
ford also had a great run so great
the only four books i read are henry's
that's like saying you worked with like
oh yeah
the one i love is called the
international
the world's foremost problem i i do like
that it's like wow he worked for four
presidents he's like yeah all one-term
presidents that's like that's like
saying i worked with four
all-star uh [ __ ] quarterbacks and
it's as a coach and you're like
yeah because every year one of them
[ __ ] broke their just snapped their
acl and were out forever
i'll have you know i was ryan leaf's
coach
[Laughter]
cfl the youngest u.s secretary of
defense
in history yeah back then the youngest
u.s secretary of defense was still 60.
16 years later rumsfeld returned to the
pentagon under president george w
bush this time as the oldest secretary
of defense
on 9 11 rumsfeld was at his desk when al
qaeda attacked the us
and flew a plane into the pentagon
rumsfeld quickly seized almost total
control of america's war on terror you
had seen
donald rumsfeld just running out from
the smoke with just
[ __ ] suitcases and monies pouring out
of them
cartoon style cartoon pills are falling
out of the side yeah
no one saw it until right my now
yeah everyone's looking for the plane
that hit it but he's just him on the
corner which is
like you said bags with dollar signs on
them
it says not money
airstrikes in afghanistan in less than
30 days
wow that's impressive yeah but look we
were long gone out of the middle east
okay that was that was 2001 it's not
like we're
still there okay dude i remember when
this war started and i remember thinking
like this will be in and out
it's afghanistan bing bang boom right no
we really did think that
everyone was like we're going to be in
and out this is nothing no one can
[ __ ] take
we're america [ __ ] you know you
you you're terrified at the sight of us
maybe they had f-15s and nukes that's
how they did it
and there were a few people like i don't
know i don't want to get into nation
building and we're like oh
come on what have we ever been on our
nation but we're gonna stay and police
the police for 20 years
stop it jesus christ why don't you tell
us another one tucker
you [ __ ] what did he call him fascist
something fascist
he says fox fashion [ __ ] fashion
fascist mondays or something no it was
fridays or something it has to be
another f
merch no it was a monday he's just that
he's just no but it was a monday
keith olbermann is just a stupid drunk
right yes
18 months the invasion of iraq but u.s
claims saddam hussein possessed weapons
of mass destruction
were soon proven false you [ __ ] you by
the way yeah you're right they were
proven false but
all of you including msnbc and cnn were
like they're totally there guys
okay they're totally there we have to do
it hey they didn't let
hans blitz into some of the rooms that's
a good point
just saying that they had it in the
dining room they could have had the nuke
in the dining room state that iraq
uh has attempted to or is willing to
supply
terrorists with weapons of mass
destruction there are known
knowns there are things we know we know
we also know there are known unknowns
but they're also unknown unknowns the
ones we don't know
we don't know that's pretty clear
honestly
how are you not following that i i don't
know i still like to this day he gets
made fun of that i know it's a weird
convoluted answer but it does make sense
kind of of course yeah it makes sense
for if you're reptoid
it makes sense if you're a lizard person
it does mean it does make sense it's
just one of those i think
maybe he was trying to just throw them
off a little bit and try to move on to
the next thing
is the latter category that tend to be
the difficult ones
as the war dragged on rumsfeld himself
came under fire
also i love this world war ii the good
war iraq the wrong war no no they were
both the wrong war let's proceed with
the work to the good
war that was i would have preferred iraq
please i know who didn't make that sign
general patton
that's what if there wasn't the first
one there wouldn't have been the second
one
he had good but president bush
stood firmly behind him i'm never
disappointed in my secretary of defense
he's doing a fabulous job still rumsfeld
started to lose the confidence of the
troops at one point he appeared to
dismiss complaints their lightly armored
vehicles
did not protect them from deadly
roadside bombs yeah but now all the
troops vehicles are
armed and they're fine now and it's been
it's been 20 years guys a lot has
changed okay
they're not still driving around an
unair-conditioned humvees
in a hundred and forty-year-olds aren't
killing soldiers anymore not anything
iuds have never killed a soldier before
if you look it up as you know
you go to war with the army you have not
the harmony you might want or wish to
have at a later what i'm trying to say
is that i can't stand these
but this is what we get these [ __ ]
high school dropouts
ultimately rumsfeld was forced to resign
in november 2006
but remain steadfast to the end it may
well be comforting to some
to consider graceful exits from the
agonies
and indeed the ugliness of combat
but the enemy thinks differently but
rumsfeld refused to quit
he and his wife joyce started a
foundation to promote leadership and
public service at home
and free political and economic and also
they started they started a
charity fund to make sure that all the
people in washington dc could have as
many flies as they could eat
and dead
rumsfeld in his old age started to look
like the judge from nothing but trouble
oh god dan aykroyd yeah yeah his nose
would come off
yes feld once said if you were not
criticized
you may not be doing much by that
measure he did quite a lot
well that was some shade right there
that was a nice smug little
outro throw some stank on it at the end
there looks like he did a lot
huh am i right fellas say if people are
calling you an f slur then you're
probably doing something right well he
must have been right
every day numerous times